Alice and Bob have figured
out an amazing trick.
They're exchanging
messages by plucking
a wire either hard or soft to
transmit a zero versus a one.
However, due to gusts of
wind, false zeros or ones
can occur during transmission,
resulting in errors.
Though they figured out a
way to communicate error
free, even in the
presence of noise.
How could they do this?
In the 1940s, Richard Hamming
faced a similar problem
while working at
Bell Laboratories.
At the Bell Telephone
Laboratories, we do about 10%
of the experiments on a
computer, and about 90%
in the laboratory.
Highly expected in time we will
do 90% on the computer and 10%
in the lab.
Speed, cost, and effort
favor the computer
over the laboratory approach.
At the time, the computers
used stored information
on punch cards representing
one versus zero
with hole versus no hole.
This system was error prone,
because it was common for cards
to get bent or mis punched
in the first place.
So holes could be
missed or no holes
could be accidentally
punctured, causing flipped bits.
These errors would
cause the entire system
to halt until the error location
could be found and corrected
manually.
So Hamming took it upon himself
to devise a method which
could automatically detect
and correct single bit
errors without
interrupting calculations.
His solution was rooted in the
intuitive idea of repetition,
something we all do when
faced with interference,
or the chance that part of
our message will be corrupted.
His error correcting
codes were built
on the simple concept
of a parity bit.
A parity it is a
single bit which
is added to the end of
a message and indicates
whether the number of ones in
the message is even or odd.
If a single error
occurs, the receiver
can then detect it
because the parity
bit will no longer match.
However, to detect and
correct single errors,
Hamming needed to
add more parity bits
to identify the error location.
This leads to his seven four
code, which adds three parity
bits to each block of
four data bits as follows.
First, we start with
the three parity bits,
which can be
represented by a circle.
Now, these circles intersect
to produce four regions,
and the four data
bits are placed
inside these regions
in a specific order.
Now, to calculate
the parity bits,
we look at each
circle one at a time,
each containing three data bits.
We determine the
parity bit as before.
Add up the data bits, and
if we get zero or two,
the parity bit is zero for even,
and if we get one or three,
the parity is one for odd.
And we do this for all circles,
and end up with three parity
bits to match the
four data bits.
These are then placed in a
standard sequence as follows.
Realize now this system
can automatically
correct single errors
with a simple rule.
If a single character occurs,
two or more of the parity bits
will be incorrect, and
wherever they intersect
is the location of the error.
This intersecting data bit
is then flipped automatically
so that all parity
bits are valid again.
And this is Alice
and Bob's trick,
the additional parity bits
are known as redundant bits,
because they don't carry
any new information.
And all air correction codes
work this way, they all
increase the size of
the source messages
slightly at the expense of
automatically correcting
errors.
We also use error correcting
codes for storage, for example,
on a physical CD,
the information
is encoded using special codes
to correct for chunks of errors
caused by scratches or dust,
which corrupt longer sequences
of zeros and ones
stored on the surface.
This is why you can
scratch a CD and often it
will still play perfectly.
Claude Shannon used
this idea of redundancy
to redefine the capacity
of a communication channel,
because as the noise on
your channel increases,
we must increase the
amount of redundancy
to communicate error
free, and this must then
decrease the effective
amount of information
you can send per unit time.